[Music]
breaking news this Wednesday night a
special rapporteur appointed the Prime
Minister names the person who will
oversee probes into election
interference
another bank falters this time in
Switzerland credit Swiss has a lot of
links to
um the financial sectors of other
countries why shares of Credit Suisse
have sunk in what it says about the
industry
Cyclone Freddy's ferocity shattering
lives and likely weather records too
well it was almost essentially
unbelievable what sets this Cyclone
apart from other stores
and we have liftoff go falcon go Dragon
Al McMaster University's space mission
could help keep astronauts healthy
foreign
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
the Prime Minister has announced who
will have the investigation into
election interference in Canada former
governor general and former law
professor David Johnston will be the
so-called special rapper tour a role the
Prime Minister created last week saying
the person appointed will have a wide
mandate and make expert recommendations
on combating interference and
strengthening Canada's democracy
Johnston who is 81 years old was
appointed Governor General in 2010 by
then Prime Minister Stephen Harper and
he held the role until 2017. our chief
political correspondent David Aiken is
with me David what the opposition really
wants is a public inquiry so what's the
reaction so far to David Johnston's
appointment yeah and that's exactly what
it is Donna all those opposition parties
are out with statements saying we want a
public inquiry we don't want a special
rapper tour but if there has to be a
special rapper tour the block the NDP
saying okay I guess it's going to be
difficult to claim David Johnston has
any partisan who you now Pierre pauliev
says he was not consulted on Johnson's
appointment and some of Peoria's
advisors one of them being Jenny Byrne a
very close advisors she's tweeting her
skepticism that Johnson might be a
neutral appointment because she doesn't
like the word Johnson has done as head
of the leaders election debate
commission and she doesn't like the fact
that Johnson sits on the board of the
Trudeau foundation and Donna I have to
point out that Foundation has nothing to
do with Justin Trudeau it's his dad
Pierre it has nothing to do with
politics nothing to do with elections in
any event as you mentioned uh Johnson
was appointed by Stephen Harper and when
Stephen Harper appointed David Johnson
he said that Johnson is the represents
the best of Canada Johnson represents
hard work dedication public service and
humility end quote that's Stephen Harper
now Johnson has been called upon often
to be an independent Arbiter and our
political process he's starting way back
in 1984 in that famous election debate
between Brian Mulroney and and John
Turner that's the one where mulrooney
had that famous line you had a choice
sir as you mentioned he's a
constitutional lawyer law professor
eventually became president at the
University of Waterloo so that's Johnson
now the big question he's been asked to
answer do those allegations of foreign
election interference many of which were
first reported right here on global news
do those allegations require a public
inquiry all three opposition parties say
yes definitely needed the Prime Minister
has not ruled it out he argues his
government is doing something else about
the issue of foreign interference but
Trudeau is on the record saying that if
his special rapper tour David Johnson
says a public Inquirer is in fact
warranted then a public inquiry will be
convened Johnson will also make other
recommendations as he sees fit on ways
to further protect our democracy uphold
confidence in our elections now
how long will Johnson have to do all
this work that is TBD Donna okay lots
more to come thanks David we'll come
back to you again a little later on
another story the former head of
Canada's covid-19 vaccine program who
was removed after sexual assault
allegations came to light and was later
acquitted is now suing the federal
government in a wide-ranging lawsuit
Major General Danny Fortes claiming six
million dollars in Damages for what the
suit called's reprehensible extreme
flagrant and high-handed conduct Cortez
legal team alleges defamation
misfeasance in public office conspiracy
and negligent investigation the suit
names over a dozen people including the
Prime Minister the current chief of the
defense staff and the former Health
Minister Patty haidu
in amqui Quebec the questions continue
about why anyone would intentionally run
down pedestrians on the street two men
were killed on Tuesday afternoon two
other people remain in critical
condition after the driver of a pickup
truck hit them he's been charged with
two counts of dangerous driving causing
deaths but the motive if there was one
remains a mystery turia Israeli reports
on a community in mourning
one agonizing question hangs over this
small Quebec town why did someone
deliberately drive a pickup truck into
innocent pedestrians this house may hold
some of the answers it's where the
suspect lived 38-year-old Steve Gagnon
Gaetan Trembley is his next door
neighbor
he seemed lost completely disconnected
from reality
says Daniel was a truck driver and
recently stopped working he turned
himself into police and is facing two
charges of dangerous driving causing
death investigators believe the Rampage
was premeditated but the victims were
random
I saw him get into his truck the day of
the attack say Jean comb lay back now a
chilling memory Levesque is the mayor of
the town over and has known Daniel since
he was a boy
it brings me pain like everyone here yes
also knew one of the victims 65 year old
Gerald
he was a sociable person always out
walking he was a good man 73 year old
Jean LaFreniere also died and a family
with young children was hit a
one-year-old and a three-year-old have
been released from hospital but two of
their relatives are still being treated
foreign
the tragedy in M Qui is not the first
time a vehicle has been used as a deadly
weapon just weeks ago a bus rammed into
a daycare north of Montreal in 2021 a
pickup truck plowed into five members of
a Muslim family in London Ontario while
in 2018 10 people died in the Toronto
van attack there's no way to eliminate
ramming attacks but certainly you can
diminish access to pedestrians and so
you can restrict vehicular traffic in
sensitive areas not far from the scene
of the crime members of the community of
just 6 000 people are coming to Green
we're here to give hopes as this priest
to show all is not lost the premier of
Quebec is expected to arrive here
tomorrow and a mass is planned at this
church on Friday to honor the two men
who died and the many lives Shattered by
this attack Donna all right turia Israel
and amkweep Quebec thanks
more signs of uncertainty surrounding
the banking sector tonight markets
tumbled in North America and Europe
dragged down by banking stocks and alarm
about Credit Suisse based in Switzerland
it lost a quarter of its value its
shares sinking to an all-time low today
investors already nervous about the
collapse of two U.S Regional Banks now
watching a Swiss bank falter our senior
business correspondent AG de aviola is
with me and what's going on here
investors on high alert for signs of
trouble in the financial sector Donna
and this fits the bill the Swiss Central
Bank stepped in just hours ago to offer
liquidity just in case think of it as a
financial safety net an analysts tell me
that Swiss authorities had no choice but
to step up this is Switzerland's second
largest lender a bank that is too big to
fail what triggered credit suisse's
latest troubles is the release of its
annual report which showed weakness in
the bank's Financial controls now credit
Suites has been plagued with problems
for years it's seen five successive
quarters of losses various scandals a
series of executive changes and client
withdrawals and when we talk about
contagion this may be a case of
psychological if not Financial contagion
and the sort of contagion not because
they had any connection with with Credit
Suisse but because investor sentiment
change of people were scrutinizing other
Banks more carefully uh and Credit
Suisse is seen as the weakest link now
the offer of help from the Swiss Central
bank is welcome news because credit
suisse's top shareholder the Saudi
National Bank said it wasn't going to
invest more in Credit Suisse because
increasing its stake would trigger
regulatory complications Donna all right
and investors certainly wary what
happened to banking stocks overall today
uh they took a pummeling for the most
part European markets closed sharply
lower North American Stock markets as
you mentioned were mostly in the red too
including the TSX investors are really
nervous about this but they're also
digesting news that the American economy
slowed last month and investors are
worried that this crisis isn't over
despite reassurances from government
officials all around the world we are
likely to see more turmoil before this
is fully behind us but one thing to keep
in mind if some of this feels eerily
reminiscent of 2007 major banks are
overall a much more solid Financial
footing than they were back then Donna
right and gaviola in Toronto thanks
in Texas a judge heard arguments today
in a case about whether a commonly used
abortion pill should be sold in the U.S
and depending on his ruling access to
the medication could be curtailed across
the country a conservative group argued
the safety of the abortion pill was
never properly studied even though it's
been approved for use for 20 years our
Washington bureau chief Jackson prosco
is watching the case Jackson
Donna this case has potentially
wide-ranging implications for abortion
access across the U.S even in states
where abortion is still fully legal a
Conservative Christian group in Texas
asked a judge to order the U.S Food and
Drug Administration to pull the abortion
drug metha Preston off the market that's
significant because medical abortions
using drugs not surgery make up about
half of pregnancy terminations in the
U.S the group behind the lawsuit argued
the drug should never have been approved
claiming it didn't go through proper
safety evaluations an argument the judge
seemed to entertain metha Preston has
been used with a high success rate for
more than two decades in the U.S and
around the world it's considered so safe
it can actually be prescribed by
Telehealth and sent by mail in the
United States its removal from the
market would have serious impacts it is
crazy to think that it can make case
that somehow the FDA which is one of the
world's best I think Regulatory Agencies
on drugs and Therapeutics that if you
can make a case that they somehow were
not thinking about the safety and that
this was all too rushed why not make
that argument for every reproductive
drug such as birth control it's worth
pointing out this case was specifically
brought up in a jurisdiction where it
would be heard by a judge who has a
track record of anti-abortion statements
a practice known as judge shopping the
hearing wrapped with the judge saying a
final ruling will come in the next few
days the losing side is all but certain
to appeal right up to the Supreme Court
ever since the fall of Roe versus Wade
anti-abortion groups have been looking
to chip away at the few remaining legal
avenues for Reproductive care using
tactics exactly like this there's real
concern about the precedent this case
could set in allowing a judge to
interfere in regulatory decisions made
by a government agency especially when
it comes to access to certain medicines
Donna all right Jackson in Washington
thank you a big development for CP Rail
today the U.S regulator has approved its
takeover of Kansas City's Southern
Railway the 42 billion dollar merger
will create the first single line rail
network linking Canada the U.S and
Mexico the 32 thousand kilometer route
will stretch from Vancouver to St John
and South through the U.S industrial
Heartland to ports in Mexico the merged
Railway will be called Canadian Pacific
Kansas City Calgary will remain the
headquarters it will employ about 20 000
people and the company says potentially
shift up to 64 000 truckloads of goods
annually off the highways CPA is
expected to take control April 14th
Russia is warning the U.S to stop what
it calls hostile activity near its
borders and denies as fighter jets came
into contact with an unmanned American
surveillance drone the U.S maintains a
Russian fighter jet harassed and then
collided with the Drone which went down
in the Black Sea the United States will
continue to fly and to operate wherever
international law allows and it is
incumbent upon Russia
to operate as military aircraft
in a safe and professional manner
Russia claims the Drone like this one
was moving deliberately towards Russian
territory it says it will attempt to
retrieve the wreckage
streamlining Canada's foreign aid coming
up the changes Ottawa is making and the
pleas to loosen the purse strings
last month the federal government
announced it is streamlining the way it
distributes all foreign aid grants in
2021 Canada spent 8.4 billion dollars on
overseas assistance the bulk of that 5
billion was in the form of foreign aid
grants as David Akin reports
humanitarian groups worry what
streamlining that funding really means
I'm definitely uh nervous nervous to to
see what's going to be coming up and uh
so the fact that that we don't know uh
what what to expect uh is is problematic
by itself save the children Canada was
one of 75 Aid organizations worried
enough to send a joint letter to finance
minister Christian Freeland looking for
more Aid dollars among other things they
argue that the world takes note that a
wealthy country like Canada ranks just
13th among its peers when it comes to
foreign aid spending it's definitely a
bit of a stain in
Canada's sort of global role and
probably one reason why Canada was not
able to secure a seat on the on the
security Council others say it's in
Canada's own interest to spend money
helping others around the world poverty
is not good for business we're a trading
country what we want to to do is help
people get out of poverty so that they
can buy our stuff the Trudeau government
has pursued what it calls a feminist
foreign policy aiming to improve gender
equity and maternal in child health as a
top aide to two liberal International
Development ministers Louis belongsey
had a hand advancing those policies now
working outside government he too was
worried there may not be enough money in
this month's federal budget let's do
more we have a feminist policy that is
changing lives right now for millions of
women and girls around the world and now
would be the worst time to cut foreign
aid Back in 1970 Canada signed on to a
United Nations plan to spend 0.7 percent
of GDP on foreign aid 0.7 percent in
fact it was a Canadian former prime
minister Lester B Pearson who led the
way to establish that 0.7 percent
threshold so where does Canada stand
today well we're not even spending half
that amount just
0.32 percent of Canada's national income
goes to help the world's poorest people
Donna
David Aiken thanks again
a cyclone unlike any other ahead why
Freddy's track has been so devastating
for Africa
in East Africa a storm that's described
as exceptional as not only devastating
the region Cyclone Freddy has struck
twice killing over 200 people in Malawi
and Mozambique the death toll is
expected to rise in what is one of the
longest and strongest tropical storms
ever recorded Mike Armstrong explains
how the devastating system has stumped
meteorologists
Cyclone Freddy may have passed in some
areas of Mozambique but the scale of the
devastation is only starting to be
understood many of the the areas hit by
the cycle in a very rural and remote and
I think information is now just starting
to trickle in
neighboring Malawi the government has an
official death toll of 225 but that
doesn't include dozens who are still
missing torrential rain followed by
flooding and mudslides have left close
to 20 000 people without shelter
this woman says her home is being
destroyed she had a big family and they
are stranded
oh
World Meteorological organization is
still studying Freddie but says it
appears to have set records it lasted
more than five weeks and is likely the
longest tropical Cyclone on record and
it may also be the strongest well it was
almost essentially unbelievable I mean
if someone had told me this could happen
I would have said oh I don't think so
now there's another aspect of Freddy
that stands out the path it followed
this storm developed off Australia it
was named Freddy officially way back on
February 6th then crossed the Indian
Ocean gaining strength over the water as
it went Cyclone Freddy made landfall
over Madagascar February 21st and hit
the continent on the 24th now a normal
storm would stay over land and dissipate
but this one turned back it headed east
over the water again gained strength
again and then turned back West this
past weekend Freddy hit the continent a
second time it was that one-two punch
that compounded things the fact that
there is let's say no dryness of the
soils means that it can't absorb the
water so you get more flooding effects
now just as relief efforts in Malawi
have been hampered by the rain and mud
it's done the same to funerals this was
a service Wednesday the country's
president attended and called on the
International Community for help Mike
Armstrong Global News
McMaster Mission next the university
celebrates a space launch and what they
hope it leads to
[Music]
this is a great example of what
Innovation can do
this is the latest fashion in spacesuits
NASA unveiled a new spacesuit astronauts
will wear on the Artemis III mission to
the Moon scheduled for 2025 the new
suits have greater Mobility the boots
are thermally insulated for treks to the
moon's South Pole this is also the first
space suit that has been designed
specifically to fit women
a SpaceX rocket lifted off last night
from the Kennedy Space Center in Florida
and it was closely watched by a team of
students from McMaster University they
spent eight years working on a special
payload carried by the rocket a
satellite as Mike drolets as part of a
push to get young Canadians interested
in space exploration
and liftoff of PRS 27 go falcon go
Dragon it never gets old watching a
dragon roar into space even if it's just
hauling 2 800 kilos of supplies and
experiments to the International Space
Station
but tucked away within all that payload
sits the hard work of a whole bunch of
Canadian students obsessed with the
Aerospace industry before setting foot
on campus ever here at McMaster as a
high school graduate I made it a goal to
join this team and launch uh satellite
their building to space Jay Patel was
part of a large team at McMaster
University that built this high-tech
radiation detector it's not the
spaceship that will eventually fly to
Mars or the habitats that will form the
first colony on the moon but it will
help keep the astronauts on those
missions safe the data we collect is
going to be useful in terms of studying
how that radiation can affect astronauts
in elongated space missions the cubesat
program was developed by the Canadian
space agency to not only teach students
how to build stuff for space but to
actually do it four of the 15
cross-canada projects greenlit in 2018
including McMasters were part of the
launch
the Fort McMurray wildfires inspired one
that has infrared cameras to study and
hopefully prevent another disaster
seeing that something you've worked on
has gone to space it completely changes
it for you Joanne Kai was part of the
team at the University of Alberta that
built it as a third year mechanical
engineering student she didn't think
she'd get this type of opportunity until
after she graduated much less watched
the launch from a VIP only rooftop
after the launch like I was just closing
my eyes and thinking of every single
part of the satellite that I worked on
and I was like that's insane that's his
face now like this board that I worked
on this little part that I made in my
face this little thing that I held test
is in space and bigger things no doubt
are on the horizon microwave Global News
Toronto
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is Thai lake near Cornell
British Columbia thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]